[Music]
It's fine in the sense of a rider.
[music] I
'm here
ana
[music]
wh I was
Starting with Saito, the captain of the 3rd division in Saito-gun
.
It's been a long time, and they're acknowledging the power of major companies
What are you going to do without taking full advantage of his position
?
It doesn't matter what the 3rd division commander is.
I agree with you, you from Thailand,
Ah, Ha,
Namba Road,
Sanosuke.
Afternoon rom The body will also be educated, isn't it?
That's what's wrong with the 10th squad.
Shut up, hey,
yes
Shinsengumi's Takasumi 6
Saito Kuni will receive a mission from below
Matsubara-
kun,
why am I in
good shape?  Please cooperate with those who haven't painted it for a long time.
Excuse me, but
I'm recovering.  I'm not there
, I'm giving orders.
Yes,
then
I'll teach you.
Mr. Matsubara, you're a terrible
politician,
I
've come to your aid.
Yamanami Keisuke, the captain of the 3rd Division of the Prefectural Division, was arrested for the crime
of
committing seppuku last night.
Even so, Mosuke-san
, you didn't come
from Shieikan, but since when did you become Kondo's version
?
In
any case, don't allow your heart to be sexually abused.
That's the iron rule of the Shinsengumi.
Yamanami knew that and left her body
.
There are no exceptions to the purge, and there are no exceptions to the at.
Betrayal is 4.
Everyone
here should keep this in mind
.